leadership has been tremendously
important during this current period you
know having the right kind of style of
leadership that can balance the
necessary tough messages of a difficult
time with enough of a sense of the foot
and tomorrow has been one of the real
challenges for leaders over this past
period and now as the mood changes and
the need to get on the front foot and
think about growth returns it's also
important for leaders to get that
balance right because people cannot be
too overly optimistic at the same time
people do are looking for people to
paint a very clear picture about the
medium to long term vision for their
organizations and to start see the
choices that are being made the
strategic investments that are being
placed or against some kind of a sense
of a longer-term picture and so leaders
have a real imperative right now to keep
the balancing act to be between the foot
in today and the foot and tomorrow right
they need to be also spending a lot of
time with their people with their
organization really bringing the top
team along with them but also in
communicating often and frequently down
through the organization both around
tough actions are still being taken now
but also importantly begin to paint that
that very clear picture about where
organizations need to go in the future
managing talent is a durable theme for
all organizations and clearly most
companies have gone through a very tough
time in terms of the actions they've had
to take whether it's been in terms of
Workforce action whether it's been in
terms of payroll actions or indeed
compensation and promotion actions many
organizations have been through a period
of time when the signals they can send
to their workforces have been tough I
think the critical thing has been about
the way that people have handled that in
terms of the integrity and the honesty
and the clarity of the communication
that's associate itself with necessary
actions now we need to start to see your
the dial turning again as people have to
start think about how do I now put back
some of the things that maybe I've not
been able to afford to do over the past
period how do I start to paint a picture
of where the organization is going and
start to send signals through my actions
that you know this is a good place to
work and there's an opportunity for
people to really you know again set
themselves up for the next stage of
their career in organizations I think
it's also important for leaders to be
looking to make sure they're accessing
new pools of talent that are out there
we're about to engage I'm sure in the
next wave of the war for talent and
that's going to mean that organizations
have to be very very sharp around how
they keep their current people motivated
but also most importantly how they tap
into new source of talent globally
around the world to enable their
business plans
well clearly sustainability as a topic
was very top of mind going into the
downturn and it was also clear that
frankly in terms of many companies
corporate priorities during that period
it was quite hard to maintain a focus on
that having said that yo good
organizations did link things like their
cost management approaches with green
approaches they tried to be lean and
green they try to think about how they
combine opportunities for cost take out
with a broader business intent around
how they provide sustainable business I
think going forward we're going to see a
very increased focus on sustainability
in its broadest sense everything from
yes how do I have an organization that
is actually operating in a green way how
do I respond to carbon trading carbon
regulations in my own organization what
that means my supply chain for my IT my
buildings etc but we're also going to
see I think a broader issue around
sustainability which is about how do I
build back business trust because we're
clearly seeing a world we're doing this
to pass down turn your trust in
organizations and in business in
particular has been eroded and it's
going to be really important for
companies for brands to be thinking
about what am i doing to really build
back trust in my organization and that's
part of doing that in the light of
creating a sustainable business that's
got long-term position with the multiple
stakeholders as the deal with in the
community